good afternoon everyone welcome to this
week's
college readout which is on the package
adopted by the college today on save gas
for a safe winter and immediately passed
the floor to the president of the
european commission yes thank you very
much indeed we want to debrief together
from
this college
the decisions we've taken with mostly
the focus on gas
demand
we know that today
the start of the russian war of
aggression against ukraine is at day 147
but if we look in hindsight we see that
months before the war broke out
russia kept gas supply
intentionally
as low as possible despite the high gas
prices we've discussed it here in this
room many times
we have seen that gas form had not the
slightest interest to balance the market
on the contrary it kept its storage
levels as low as possible and the
supplies too and therefore reducing the
supply tightening the market and driving
up the prices
what do we see today
today we have 12 member states
that are hit by a partial cutoff of
russian gas or a total cut off of
russian gas supply
and overall the flow of russian gas is
now less than one-third
to what it used to be for example at the
same time last year
russia is blackmailing us
russia is using energy as a weapon
and therefore in any event whether it's
a partial
major cutoff of russian gas or total
cutoff of russian gas europe needs to be
ready
we do not start from scratch and that's
good we have already done a lot
to reduce our dependency on russian
fossil fuels overall
we've set up a joint gas storage the
storages are now filled with 64 percent
we set up an eu energy platform for
joint purchase
we have
proposed our re-power eu plan
and you know it's two pillars the one is
on supply
increase the supply from other
transverse resources than the russian
and the second pillar is on reduce the
demand demand overall
on gas
perhaps on the first pillar
the gas supply from other sources than
russia
have quite
quite impressively increased since
january this year
by 35 bcm by now
so you remember that we had the u.s
agreement on in greece to increase
supplies on lng
um norway stepped up considerably qatar
the gulf states algeria i was with kadri
in egypt to sign an mou on more supplies
we were two days ago in azerbaijan to
sign an mou on increased supplies
and we have worked a lot on increased
supplies through renewable energy this
is the energy of the future this is the
energy we need besides the fact that it
is clean energy it is homegrown and
makes us independent and there we have
also good news because since the
beginning of this year
we have an estimated additional 20
gigawatt of renewable energy capacity if
you put that as an equivalent to gas
it's round about 4bcm
replaced by renewables by now
today we want to focus on the demand
side
the energy saving and
we here too do not start at scratch the
member states are doing already a lot
what is the state of play right now
we have right now 11 member states that
have triggered an early warning what the
gas supply is concerned and one member
state has even triggered an alert
but we also know that we have to prepare
for more
the preparation is not enough
we have to address and this is for the
first time our energy security at a
european level
we have to be proactive
we have to prepare for a potential full
disruption of russian gas
and this is a likely scenario what we've
seen in the past as we know russia is
calculatingly trying to put pressure on
us by reducing the supply of gas so it
is a likely scenario that there's a full
cutoff of russian gas and that would
hit the whole european union a gas
crisis in the eu's single market our
economic powerhouse will affect every
single member state in our european
union
now we have learned our lesson from the
pandemic we know that in such kind of a
crisis our worst enemy is fragmentation
and if we act in unity
we can address any crisis we are much
much stronger than the sum of 27 member
states only and we know a lot of at
stake the well-being of our citizens the
jobs our economy so if we can act in
unity we can master the difficulties
what is the proposal
to make it through the winter
assuming there is a full disruption of
russian gas
we need to save gas to fill our gas
storages faster
and to do so we have to reduce our gas
consumption
i know this is a big ask
for the whole of the european union
but it is necessary to to protect us
and this is why today we propose an
emergency instrument on the basis of
article 122.
we have two objectives one is every
member state should reduce the use of
gas
and our second objective is we provide a
safety net
for all member states
on the reduce of gas use
in case
that we have a situation that
deteriorates like the full disruption of
russian gas
we trigger an eu alert
overall for the european union
we are asking the member states to
reduce by 15
the gas consumption
15
y this is the equivalent to 45 bcm of
gas
and with such a reduction we can make it
safely through this winter
in case of a complete disruption of
russian gas
this is calculated under certain
assumptions
but this would bring us if we save 15 to
the storage safely through the winter
and the motto is the quicker we act the
more we save the safer we are
on our second objective solidarity
there are some member states that are
more directly exposed than others to
russian gas and they are of course more
vulnerable than others to risk
disruption
but all member states
will suffer the consequences of such a
disruption through the single market so
this is why
it is important that all member states
now contribute in the saving the storing
and are ready to share gas with the
other neighbors in case of need
energy solidarity is a core principle of
our treaty
we have already the security of supply
regulation that foresees that member
states can count on each other
and we are building on that the
emergency instrument that we present
today
i know these are testing kinds
but we also know by experience now in
the crisis we've gone through
that testing times require that we are
well organized well coordinated on a
european level
that we show strong unity
and that we show solidarity these are
the three ingredients that make us
strong and make it possible to go
through any kind of crisis we've managed
the pandemic we've managed the
vaccination in that way we've managed to
create next generation eu
we've used this unity this european
coordination and the solidarity with
facing russia's war
we've gone through applying six packages
of sanctions the seventh is underway
so if we look at the european union
today i am confident that we can master
this russian-engineered energy crisis by
staying together thank you
thank you very much president now
executive as president you have the
floor
thank you very much and and good
afternoon uh testing times as the
president
has just said and we are faced with an
energy security situation that is
unprecedented
and indeed it is
a political creation
by
president putin
as part of his efforts to weaken us and
to
divide us
and in response to such a political
action political counteraction
is necessary
russia sees
gas as a political weapon
so we need to have at european level a
political response
it's not easy to predict what putin's
next move will be
but that he will continue to try and
divide us
and to hurt us is clear
so
what we need to do in any case is to
prepare
for even the possibility of full
disruption of gas supplies all scenarios
should be taken into account even that
worse scenario
that's why in the heat of summer we have
to think about winter
we need to save gas now to keep our
homes heated and industry running when
winter comes
so when we say winter is coming we just
announced that the
season is changing we're not just we're
not quoting a game of thrones
and we can do that
if we do nothing
once things show we will have shortfalls
and shortfalls would not just affect the
countries where the shortfalls happen
they will affect every single member
state because they will have serious
consequences on our economy
and nobody can escape
that consequence
so the choice we have today is
triggering solidarity now
or waiting for an emergency that will
force solidarity upon us
when the circumstances then will be much
uglier and the response will have to be
much
more complicated
so
if there would be a complete halt of
russian gas supplies
we will most likely fail to put enough
gas into storage and next winter the
winter after next winter the situation
could be even more dire
so we
cannot in good conscience
allow the situation to spiral out of
control because it will as i said also
cause significant economic damage
but we can reduce potential gdp losses
if we apply preventive reductions now
instead of taking reactive measures
later if we do that we can say to
european citizens you will not be in the
cold and you will not be out of your job
because europe has shown solidarity
we believe the situation is urgent
enough to invoke article 122. we're
calling on member states to make
voluntary cuts now we also need the
possibility for mandatory demand
reduction if the situation
gets worse and we would then propose to
the council to take a decision to go
into
that direction
we've opted to
set a uniform target because it is the
simplest fastest fairest and also most
transparent way forward
every member state will need to take
measures relative to their own average
consumption
we will work together with industry to
identify how to scale back and where
chiri will certainly have a lot to say
about that
and let me just underline this
households and other protected consumers
will remain protected
but they can also contribute
by
cutting the gas consumption
many of the possible savings are no
regret measures think about it
do we need to have the lights on and
empty office buildings or shop fronts
all night
do we have to have air conditioning set
at 20 degrees could be higher couldn't
it
of course it might reduce a bit of our
comfort
but it might also reduce a lot of our
consumption
and
none of this will be easy
but if we act now we have a choice about
how we do it we remain masters of our
own destiny if we really do this
if we choose now to plan for managed
cuts to develop contingency measures
together with industry and give up a few
comforts ourselves every one of us
we avoid a full-blown crisis next winter
we must use all the tools we have
energy savings of course
but also the other pillars of repower eu
and i urge the council to work hard on
making it on translating our proposals
into facts
we need to keep diversifying our energy
supplies the eu energy platform can
support joint purchasing and coordinate
distribution of gas across the eu
and the rollout of renewable energy must
continue to accelerate
as the imf has recently
studied
the trend the cost of transition to
renewables
is lower than continuing
with
fossil fuel just imagine that the cost
is lower than continuing with fossil
fuels so transitioning is cheaper than
staying where we are and this i think we
should keep in mind
um
if we can put this together and i think
we can
and i think we need to do that
then putin's
attempt to manipulate us will fail
because he's not attacking individual
countries sure he will but his plan is
to attack individual countries
to weaken
europe as a whole so europe as a whole
is
under his attack
a strong european response is the only
response
unilateral measures are not the way to
go they create severe distortions in the
internal markets they're ineffective and
they can put the energy security of the
entire eu at risk and we don't want to
give that gift to mr putin we have to
move forward in solidarity standing
together and using our strength as a
union thank you
thank you very much commissioner simpson
thank you president thank you france uh
you have outlined very clearly the
situation we are facing right now and
why we need to act um quickly decisively
and together and let me add a few more
details
the possibility of russia cutting off
the gossip like europe hangs over us
every day
we committed and reap our eu to end our
dependence as soon as possible and
reduce
it by two-thirds already this year
through diversification renewables and
energy efficiency but we acknowledge
them that even with these accelerated
efforts we will not get to zero in the
matter of months
we have carefully analyzed together with
nz
but the full disruption of gas this year
would mean for our security supply and
the message is clear
if there is a full disruption we will
face a gap between gas supply and demand
we estimate that this cap would be
around
30 billion cubic meters in an average
winter 45 bcm in colder one and even
larger if the winter is exceptionally
gold
and i assume that
also that
non-russian lng and pipeline supply will
remain high
through the winter
to address that remaining dependence on
russia
we need to reduce gas demand and we must
also preserve our ability to fill gas
storage
for this coming winter and for the next
one
so member states have made
already remarkable progress despite the
challenging situation on the gas market
and the feeling level today is very
close to 65 percent
but if the supplies from russia are cut
reaching our 80
target by november will be become very
challenging
and if we if our demand reduction
target is not ambitious enough we are
scanning this winter with empty storage
which would be impossible to refill in
time of the next heating season
taking all these factors into account
we're proposing a 15 reaction of gas
consumption from the beginning of august
to the end of march
this corresponds to 45 bcm of gas and
will significantly reduce security
supply risks
by acting together in a coordinated and
proactive way it is us who decides our
energy policies not put in
and by taking early action we reduce the
impact on the eu eu economies protecting
our people and businesses
delaying comes with cost
it increases the negative impact on the
gdp
by at least a third in our main scenario
this could mean a difference between a
0.6 and a 1.5 reduction of gdp and to be
prepared for this winter we have put
forward the legal proposal with a
two-step approach
in the first stage we call member states
to reduce cast demand by 15
on a voluntary basis compared to their
own consumption
over an historical five-year average
if the member states are not making
sufficient progress
or the situation deteriorates
we propose that the commission can
declare a state of eu alert
at any moment
and this will trigger a mandatory
obligation for the member states to meet
the 15 gas reduction target
we are not telling the member stage
bits which matters
they need to take as they are the best
place to know what works for their
energy system and economy but to help
them to implement ambitious goal
we have also outlined options for
voluntary gas savings from fuel switch
to demand
reduction
the aim of these measures is to avoid
the need for forced containment of
industry however if it does become
necessary we have set out guidance for
member states how to take these
difficult decisions and gerry will say
more about that
in the eu
households are protected consumers
and there should be no risk of anyone
being cut off
heating as the gas supplied homes is
safeguarded
but everyone can and should
save gas and we will continue to promote
the ideas set out in the eu energy
saving plan and ask all member states to
launch awareness campaigns to encourage
gas saving behavior
there is also considerable potential for
the public sector to reduce demand
especially in heating and cooling
let me end by saying that today's
package has a very clear and specific
purpose
to reduce overcast demand and in
parallel
intense work continues on the supply
side
in the first half of the year
lng's applies to the eu increased by 25
bcm and pipeline deliveries by 14
billion cubic meters in total we have
received an extra
35 bcm of non-russian gas this year and
the target of 3-power eu plan was 60 pcm
of additional supplies in 2022.
the president that i just returned from
azerbaijan where we agreed to more than
double the gas volumes to the eu by 2027
and we expect to see an increase up to
four pcm extra already this year and we
have also agreements in place
the united states can add an all the
egypt and israel long working
relationship with qatar
and
and algeria
all the work streams laid out in
re-power youth
diversification
joint gas purchases ramping up
renewables and hydrogen increasing
energy efficience and tackling high
prices
remain an absolute
priorities
so this winter
will be a test for the use of energy
system and for our union as a whole
and it is a test that we will pass if we
act this unity solidarity and resolve
thank you
thank you very much
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
is
subscribe
[Music]
[Music]
oliver
thanks hi in the middle of working with
your newspaper depressed um
unfortunately it didn't have the
opportunity to read the actual legal
proposal because we haven't received it
and the link in the documents you sent
isn't working but uh my question is
is there anything about
um
a cut on
cryptocurrencies we know that these are
enormous enormous gobblers of energy and
their economic purpose and use is a bit
questionable we learned that for example
producing bitcoins is using as much
energy as as the country of sweden is
using so
are you planning to do something on this
form of uh of speculative activity
you're asking people to heat less you're
asking people to
to chill their homes less what are you
doing to go after this form of of energy
consumption thank you
yes indeed in the autumn um well
we are preparing me and my services a
communication on on the digitalization
in the energy sector and the mining of
cryptocurrencies will be also addressed
there in today's proposal will
will guide member states not only to
cut the consumption of gas but also
to look into the response demand if we
can if we manage to well avoid the big
hours that means that in power
regeneration there will be less hours
when
gas by power plants will meet the peak
demand
and this is one option how member states
can cut the
demand for gas
thank you
for all proposals
yes perhaps yes president the overall
proposal
has the principle
and this is very clear
that it is up to the member states with
very different energy mixes they have
to decide on um how to move forward and
how to save gas but
the overall proposal also encourages and
shows that
with our coordination on a european
level
we're giving guidance we're showing best
practices we're exchanging knowledge on
what are good ways
right now to save energy
and for example some member states have
started
to have the market auctioning of gas so
it's organized by the companies
themselves they offer gas that they
don't need right now to a certain price
and somebody else another company might
take it so you have a market-based
mechanism already to increase the
efficiency and
to decrease the use of gas and there are
many good ideas i want to emphasize
that right now
the 15
are aspirational it's a voluntary goal
it's aspirational
and in case that we are in an emergency
then
the target becomes binding so it's time
right now it's the time right now to
really use the best practices the ideas
that out there them quite some
experiences of the member states how to
reduce gas and everyone can contribute
every single citizen every single
businesses every single public
institution can contribute
yes delay it back yes
yes
you need your mic and you need to
present yourself please well your mic is
next to your seat
we have gone so virtual that uh we have
forgotten how to use a pressure go ahead
now do you hear me yeah my name is
sullivan
i work for a danish daily called
berlinski and my question goes to a
madam president i wonder how emergent
would you say these measures are
the war started on february february
24th
could you is this something we could
even the member states could maybe even
have done a little bit earlier on thank
you
the member states do a lot already
um and you see it at the different
levels they have raised awareness and
attention as i said i think it was 11
member states that have already an early
warning and this has consequences so
recommendations how to save gas and one
member state already triggered the alert
level which is the second level
afterwards comes then the emergency
level so
there's a strong debate out there and
strong recommendations
really to to to save gas already
and i think it is important that we also
see that
we have on the supply side
in the last six months since the war
started
being able to
attract
more gas from non-russian sources
then russia decreased its supply of gas
so we have been overshooting already
with non-russian gas if i may call it
that way
also to fill our storages that is that
is the main purpose
right now
and there are many good ideas out there
that the member states can use
yes please
good afternoon christopher the
netherlands
next week the energy ministers will talk
about your proposals and probably there
will be a vote with qualified majority
what happens in the case when some
countries are not willing to participate
and are outvoted what are your legal
instruments uh when they don't want to
commit themselves to the 15 percent
thank you
so the legal instruments is the whole
menu that we have to
enforce um the law
but important is also
i think this is
something like i would call the absolute
last resort this is not the main way we
deal with each other it's i think
creating the awareness
how interdependent we are and how much
it is important that we save now gas in
order to have
no severe recession on our single market
because if we want to go against a
darker scenario we now have to save the
gas altogether to protect our single
market that is our economic powerhouse
and this is our strongest leverage that
we do have
and um we have
a part in
the the proposal today
that gives every member state the
possibility to present its case
with the different figures
so that we look at all the possibilities
that are out there
right now is the phase really to create
create and to
remind the member states how strong we
are when we are when we show solidarity
we have to keep the vivid memory of the
pandemic in mind we were
after
really showing solidarity really good
this is the region one of the regions in
the world that went the best through the
pandemic as difficult as it was and it's
not over right now but what we are able
to do and to create uh when it's getting
uh when it's really getting rough and
tough how strong we are with solidarity
and therefore putin
is trying to push us around this winter
and he will dramatically fail
if we stick together and we'll get them
stronger out of this crisis than we went
into this crisis i'm deeply convinced
thank you i will go to the platform for
a few questions before going back to the
room and i give the floor to ardish adi
stamadin
um in a west television um i'd ever
switch to dutch with a question for mr
timmermans
from
[Music]
uh
um
so we had a slight issue with
interpretation actually we don't have
today dutch interpretation it worked
into english we were we were lucky that
i'm not sure exactly so let's let's uh
let's be wary of that apologies for this
um okay fully french on you if you don't
have dutch interpretations
you have the languages into which we can
interpret today on the on the table go
ahead are we speaking i speak english i
think it's the easiest way
um there are some member states who
are somewhat skeptical about your idea
of a flat percentage for everybody i
know of course everyone has a different
basis on the five years and so on
but there are some member states who are
saying we were more advanced last year
in cutting gas and now we have much less
room maneuver for cutting even more so
for us in would be more expensive than
for other member states have done less
they have more room of maneuver so um
you said already that this 15 means the
flat is the
simplest and clearest
solution
but i mean if you can just elaborate
more and how can you address these
doubts thank you
there is a reason why we've taken the
last five years on average the gas
consumption between august and march
so
corona is in the years before corona so
there's a really
a
leveled and balanced basis and from that
basis on you have to reduce 15
so if you've done already a lot that's
good because you're better than the
average of the last five years
if you have not done a lot
and you have a high gas consumption
well it is necessary really to start not
to be very serious on that because you
might otherwise
have a problem if the market is further
tightening
because of a full
disruption of russian gas
and therefore
i think it is a fair it's a balanced
uh metric that we are using
um i know that there are different
situations the energy mix is completely
different in different member states but
in the very end
why are we doing that it's not only the
focus on gas it's the focus here on
energy security for the single market
and by saving now
we can take much softer measures as we
would have to take in case of a
full-blown emergency immediately
and that's the purpose to have now the
soft measures to have more time to apply
that to adapt
to
i mean many many citizens are asking how
can i help because they want to be part
of
fighting this russian war of aggression
in ukraine
businesses are willing to work with best
practices if they have good examples
from other parts of europe from other
member states so there are many
possibilities really to go into the
energy efficiency by the way
it is also very important that's not the
main driver but as a side effect
overall we have to reduce our dependency
on fossil fuels
i mean we have in the back always the
looming
climate crisis that is huge and we see
the effects around us on a daily basis
so getting serious on that has many
advantages my last remark on it
the solidarity is also not only the
sharing but other the so sorry the
saving but also the sharing there are
many different options either you have
the pipeline connections the
interconnectors you can share
share gas by that
or you can swap your contracts for
example lng that does not come to your
member state but goes to another one
another
liquefying station where it's more
needed
so
we are preparing for the worst hoping
for the best
but what we do now is we we urge member
states to do it in time
then overall the impact negative impact
on the single market will be much less
and
the the move towards our independence of
russian fossil fuels faster
thank you very much i continue on the
platform and i give the photo to
emmanuel beretta
plays
uh
[Music]
[Music]
mrs simpson so tim and runs you want to
have anything on this no
okay then we move to this yeah the
second is on the
turbine
um that went to canada it's now already
in transit back
so there is no pretext not to deliver
gas
um by the way there are potentially also
alternative turbines that fit it's not a
one and single turbine in the world but
there are identical turbines
it is in transit it will be there in
time no pretext
to not to deliver we have heard
putin today
elaborate on no stream one and no stream
two here i want to be very clear no
stream two is not even certified and not
at all operational also to be clear on
that one
thank you sam
thanks a couple questions
just like to pick up on the on the
second one on nordstrom one you are you
now anticipating that um nordstrom one
will indeed be operational and i mean to
what extent to what what um from from
this week and do you how much weight do
you put on
the signals that russia is giving that
it could resume shipments and then on
the the emergency mechanism itself if
you move from 15 voluntary to mandatory
could you just give us a little bit more
of a sign of a sense of what the
circumstances would be if you moved to
mandatory
is it a full shutoff that you're talking
about which which triggers that
or is it that the member states
themselves are falling behind
when it comes to meeting their
commitments on a voluntary basis thanks
so on your your first question i think
we should be very clear gazprom has
proven to be a completely unreliable
supplier and behind gus prom is as we
know putin
so um it is not predictable what's going
to happen that's very simple
and
therefore i will not elaborate about
different scenarios
that's the reason why we prepare uh for
the the worst scenario very clearly
and the trigger
the trigger
for the
emergency situation is either a drastic
reduction of
russian gas or complete cut off of
russian gas
that then will go into
the binding
the binding phase
and
you know that there are some assumptions
i think we spoke briefly about them
already
the 15 percent are the amount that we
have to save to make it through the
winter
from now on anytime whenever this
emergency level is reached it's good to
save already right now because this
gives us more time
it's under the assumption we will have a
cold to average winter under the
assumption we have the high levels of
lng ongoing that we had right now and of
course that we use our storage as much
as possible
thank you very much um i go back to the
platform and i give the photo to susanna
uh thank you i have a question on
solidarity so i suppose that this is
also a request for countries like
portugal that are not dependent on
russian gas
so do you think it's going to be easy
first to ask for cuts in in countries
that
actually are not that dependent on the
russian gas and then
do you think it's going to be easy to to
to allow the sharing if needed
and also you are asking about you are
talking about um a voluntary cut
but at the national level i suppose we
are talking about mandatory cuts
otherwise how can you
how can uh one can be how can one be
sure that the cuts that the 15 percent
cuts is going to be rich or met thank
you
i would start on it but then i would
encourage also yeah thank you cathy
one point one thing is important
if you look at the different member
states they are good example of member
states that have reduced their gas
consumption
quite impressively already
so there are ways and means to do that
and the good part is we buy time right
now in being so early
with this proposal there are good ways
to slowly but surely reduce your
consumption
the calculation we've done again i would
like to remind is from now until the end
of march these 15 have to be reduced and
there are many many ways to do it i
would just encourage to to
look into the details everyone can
contribute uh to that
and
indeed on on the first question on
portugal
curry if you would like
yes indeed we are already in this
situation where several member states
have cut their consumption compared to
five year average um historical average
the best example is finland was among
first ones who was cut off from russian
supplies they have cut 54
of their gas consumption despite the
fact that they also lost electricity
flows from russia
another example netherlands uh i guess
france was explaining it clearly but
netherlands is one of our member states
who have
still that its own class research cast
producing country they have got 20
percent and
well member states are starting in
different positions but solidarity is
also the key for our existing gas
security of supply regulation so when we
will end up in
in the situation that there is emergence
and the curtailment needs then we will
act in spirit of solidarity
today's proposal is to avoid this
situation to come through this situation
so that we can
if we are acting in the spirit of unit
and solidarity also avoid the
announcement of alert
that means that at this current status
member states can
adopt measures that also include
households because there is a vast
potential um to save there but at the
level of emergency
households are protect consumers
and and indeed
next tuesday we will have extraordinary
energy ministers council
and i do expect that all my good
colleagues from national governments
will explain that they have done that
utmost
but
eu level savings so far
have been equal of five percent and this
is clearly not enough
so um so we have to start
well coordinated savings programs right
now if we don't want to face the worst
case scenario in the middle of the
winter and well just my last comment on
north stream one well there are other
pipelines who are delivering russian gas
right now but at very low volumes so if
it would be only technical issue
there are well
connections by turkey and ukraine that
responsible trading partner could use
this is not the case right now thank you
thank you very much marco
yeah thank you very much marco brazolin
last time i have a question for the
president
in the first phase the the reduction of
consumption will be on a voluntary basis
basis so
how will you
incentivize member states to follow
these
let's say recommendation i mean
when if and when the target will become
mandatory uh are you going to count
these 15 from this moment or are you
going to take in account uh from the
first of august in order to to take in
account the effort already made on the
on a voluntary basis
thank you for the question because we
obviously have to be better in
explaining
the calculation
we take the last five years
always the gas consumption from august
till march
so 21 20 19 18 17.
and there you have the average
this is the basis from which on you're
counting
and then we say from this basis on
please reduce 15
um
some have already been coupled with the
commissioner simpson was already
explaining that finland is outstanding
so it has already done its job in
reducing from its own
average the last five years
more than 15 gas consumptions
therefore the month is not relevant it's
the amount that you have to reduce um
second the incentivize to how to
incentivize
the discussion has to be
look if we're getting into an emergency
situation
there's going to be a big hit in the
single market
and we know by experience
we can master that if we stick together
and if we show solidarity also in
sharing the gas
and those who are most dependent on gas
have the most russian gas
will need the most solidarity at that
point so it's in their own interest
to show solidarity in reducing
gas in the time before that might be a
full um
disruption of russian gas
yes just just to be very clear the 15
remains the 15
in both scenarios it doesn't change
because you go into another scenario
it's the same fifteen percent vis-a-vis
the average of the five people
yes yeah for the same amount yes from
now on till end of march
you have time to reduce the 15 percent
thank you very much
i now give the floor to marcus becker
marcus
that's a question for commissioner
barton
and i hope you i quote you correctly
you said that those member states who
want to receive solidarity will have to
show that they have taken all measures
to reduce their consumption so it is a
hard precondition in other words
if a member states
will have made
no
not enough
efforts to to reduce its consumption
will it then be somehow excluded from
solidarity and one question for
president frondeline it's about hungary
last week hungary announced that from
now on there will be no experts anymore
no energy experts to other member states
how do you look at that and how might
this affect
hungary's role or hungary's perception
of eu solidarity should it be this
well i think it's important to
understand that this is of course on a
voluntary basis but
this is why we are now discussing uh
with every single member state to see
everything
that they can do they do because of
course when
our if you will ask solidarity we want
to avoid because we went through this
together with the president at the
beginning of the last crisis we want to
avoid a country saying look you didn't
do what you had to do so i will keep
everything for me and this is why we
wanted to prevent this attitude and we
have now engaged a very comprehensive
and positive discussions with uh by the
way uh every single members test to see
what they can do
to increase and to accelerate this
substitution because i keep repeating it
the key objective
is to make sure that it will be no
disruption on the market and especially
on the single market and by the way if
you you
you you follow me uh on um
on one single point uh i i i would like
to tell you that we have also some
criterias
if there is an emergency situations and
that at the end of the day we will we
will be in a situation where when some
member states will have let's say to
reduce
from some uh uh ecosystems enterprise so
we have established very clear criterias
that everybody will follow social
criteria
supply transporters potential damage
damages to the industrial
tool for example if you get a glass
it could be very difficult to restart it
and also possible uh adjustment uh to
the consumption of gas so we are very
clear we have guidelines we have a lot
of things to share with with the member
states and we are doing this you know in
a good wheel but of course we need to
start now this is what we are doing now
and we will start
this summer thank you
on the question of hungary announcing
that they want to
reduce or stop the export of single
products in the energy sector
there's important that we protect the
single market it's one of the principles
whether it's now energy products or
other products we have asked hungary for
detailed information it always has to be
targeted it has to be proportionate and
it has to be plausible the information
is not here yet so we're looking into
that case but we will protect the single
market
cuddle you want to
well indeed hungary has not notified us
why
um and if they have announced a
emergency level but well restrictions um
on the exports in the in the internal
market can only be classified based on
very specific grounds such as the
protection of public order and public
health and economic grounds are never a
legitimate jurisdiction
and and
well there are no known disruptions for
hungary's supply
right now thank you
thank you very much this brings us to
the end of this press conference but
stay tuned we now have a technical
briefing which will allow you to
continue asking your questions thank you
very much